I'm wearing a leather shirt because I it
looked like the only thing in my closet
that wasn't wrinkled and I didn't want
to iron anything but it looks extremely
wrinkled my style icon is a box welcome
to sexy Monday I'm doing another
miscellaneous Monday of random stream of
consciousness stream of consciousness my
brain pin on you what are we talking
about today
future Grace on actual Monday will have
been on a plane going to Miami for a
convention called nat pit board as i
keep calling it nat p maybe that's why
I'm wearing this leather shirt I'm
preparing to go to Miami
Ben Bonnie nor amiami this must be what
it's like when you don't wear your
glasses do you ever just hair me let's
like the bottom of a broom and more like
the top of the head of hair what do you
call what Freud wears under his dress
before Dean slip
how many of regrettable things did you
do this weekend excellent that I tried
to say awesome and excellent in one word
talking not one of my special skills
fell asleep with my eyes open and my
hands moving for a moment in time I'm
tired of all your sake you have to show
us your body wouldn't be a body
apparently this is my impersonation of
Kanye West Who am I what is this what is
this I'm really gonna try and make
sweatpants a good thing did you guys see
I guys I've written up in the Washington
Post last week and uh it was really fun
and the photo shoot and the thing and go
look at it
translate that it's some of you were
inquiring about my feet being really
gross in the photo
well they my feet right now are
incredibly gross because I'm not gonna
show you my feet you perv hurts my feet
weren't really gross because when we did
our no filter tour in the North West I
decided I was doing a bit that involved
me sliding across the stage on my knees
and I didn't wear socks and so the tops
of my feet every night got hurt I'm very
good at storytelling talking about this
important thing if you preorder camp
Takota before 5:00 p.m. Pacific Standard
Time today we you will get an unlocked
never-before-seen scene from the movie
sent to you to watch that is
today's in the mouth hole I'm going to
leave now now I'm going to leave right
now I'm leaving now now is when the
leaving happened to now I'll leave now
in now that's what i call music volume
leave I don't know the front door you
left it open